it's once again time for our monthly
meetup as we go through the ps+
offerings for the coming month September
has 8 free games for PlayStation Plus
subscribers to download from around
midday on Tuesday except for the first
game that's available today but we'll
get to that in a moment anyway there's 7
to play on your ps4 so let's do this
destiny 2 is now free with PS Plus Wow
and it's available right now you could
download it straight away go for it give
it a download I'm sure I don't need to
explain destiny to to you all but I will
give you a quick update destiny 2 is a
first-person shooter with a huge
grinding element which keeps you coming
back daily there's character armor sets
to grind for exotic guns to find and
factions to work for and there's a story
to which I personally found very
enjoyable the thing about destiny - it
does one thing so much better than most
of the games you'll be playing right now
it's the gunplay
it's simply outstanding sadly though the
game itself took huge steps backwards
from the original destiny and it lost so
many players due to dare I say it's
awful expansions and a few shady
money-grubbing tactics that it looked
pretty bleak for destiny - but the
upcoming forsaken DLC looks to put right
all the things that were broken in the
last year now could be a great time to
try destiny again because lessons have
been learned and on September the 1st
you can try the brand new expansions
gambit mode for free for 24 hours for
the sublime gunplay alone I think it's
worth a visit but what do you think new
to destiny or have you been here before
I'd love to know your thoughts in the
comments below destiny 2 has a
Metacritic score of 85 with the
expansions earning 63 and 57 ya the
expansions weren't very good now on to a
straight-up gorefest action filled God
punching simulator all wrapped up in a
mythological bow God of War 3 remastered
take control of Kratos before he became
the ultimate dad which he is today so
forget about Norse mythology we're going
back to Greece with your trusty Blades
of Chaos climbed to the top of Mount
Olympus and have your vengeance on Zeus
if anyone asks why you're slaughtering
everyone in the Greek pantheon reassure
them it's a history project every day's
a school day
God of War three remastered holds a
Metacritic score of 81 out of a hundred
that's bloody impressive the two
additional titles from last month are
here again knowledge is power is the
play link title so you'll need your
mobile phone for that and here they lie
is far as psvr owners oh and before we
move over to the ps3 remember there's a
few goodies to download for fortnight
battle royale h1z1 and Neverwinter
mainly exclusive vanity items but I'll
put all the blurb in the description
below just in case you're wondering over
on the ps3 are two more games which can
be downloaded on your PS o first is
another world 20th anniversary edition
this is mainly for O's oldies who adore
the history of video games another world
is definitely a classic with minimal
graphics and follows a character
attempting to escape an alien planet
it's a simple left-to-right 2d tile set
with basic enemies and puzzles although
some of the puzzles will stump you for a
while if you played Abe's Oddysee or
limbo this is where they all originated
from another world can be played on your
PS Vita too
next up we have Cube director's cut this
is a first-person puzzle outing in which
you'll be manipulating your environment
by building bridges creating new paths
and just generally moving objects it
takes many cues from portal but comedy
isn't one of them the narration and the
storytelling is a little darker and the
music builds on that tension new modes
have been added such as Time Trial with
10 levels and the music I was talking
about has been updated to cube currently
has a meta score of 76 out of 100 are
you a puzzle fan grabbing it game number
7 for the month is over on the Vita
which once again can be downloaded on
the ps4 this is foul play foul play is a
beaten-up set on the theater stage as
crowds cheer you on themed brawls
include wolves mummies and bears it's a
small indie title which isn't here to
rewrite the way we play video games it's
here for some but and bashing goodness
and finally the only game on the list
which can't be played on the ps4 this is
a Vita
only this is Sparkle - it's essentially
a color based puzzler and reaction game
where you shoot colored orbs to destroy
other ops not much else to it there's a
story attached in which you'll hunt down
five enchanted keys but ultimately it's
rinse and repeat
oh so there we have it eight games to
download seven of which are on the ps4
that's pretty damn impressive Sony keep
it up I'll be grabbing God of War three
and another world but what about you and
really interested to know if anyone will
try destiny - again I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
see you next time